kanye west is moving on with model arena
shake
and kim kardashian is happy for them
i've seen him go through
a lot earlier this week et learned that
the 44 year old rapper
is casually dating the 35 year old model
and now a source tells et
that kim is cool with it explaining
quote
kim is happy for kanye and arena at the
end of the day
kim just wants kanye to be happy at the
end of the day life is about being happy
being who you are the source adds
she knows how incredible of a man he is
their relationship just ran its course
and he deserves to be with someone who
makes him happy
in february kim filed for divorce from
kanye after
six years of marriage and on the series
finale of keeping up with the
kardashians
the beauty mogul opens up to her mom
kris jenner about their marital issues
revealing the moment she realized she
was ready to move on
after turning 40 this year i realized
like no i don't want
a husband that lives in a completely
different state
to me i thought oh my god that's when
we're getting along the best
but then that is sad to me and that's
not what i want
kim also goes on to tell her momager
that although she's enjoyed all the
extravagant moments with kanye over the
years
she's ready for a different experience
in a future relationship
i want someone that we have the same
shows in common
i want someone that wants to work out
with me i have all the big things
yeah i have the extravagant everything
you could possibly imagine and no one
will ever do it like that i know that
you know what i mean and i'm grateful
for those experiences but
i think i'm ready for the smaller
experiences that
i think will mean a lot meanwhile it
seems kanye is enjoying life with arena
by his side
earlier this week the two were spotted
celebrating the rapper's 44th birthday
in provence france
as for the pair's budding relationship a
source tells et
kanye and arena have known each other
for years through the entertainment and
fashion industry
and he has always thought she was
extremely beautiful and cool
we were out of our minds to even think
like
something like this could really happen
and although a source tells et that the
situation with kim and kanye is still
pretty emotional
and not completely resolved another
source adds that even if kanye has moved
on
kim always has the support of her family
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through